as host of no reservations and parts
unknown the late anthony bourdain shared
his life in a raw unfiltered style that
made his fans feel like they knew him
and knew him well now a new book is
serving up an even more complete story
bourdain the definitive oral biography
is a collection of interviews with those
who knew him best and it will be out
tomorrow our anthony mason caught up
with several of those close friends and
he joins us now anthony um you're a
fantastic interviewer and you're seeing
interviews on the page
was what
was on the page as good as expected was
it revealing as we hoped he's such an
interesting guy you know that when you
you so many people knew him he had so
many friends and they all had very
different perspectives on him so it
makes for a very surprisingly powerful
book because it's all just interviews
and quotes from those interviews very
strong stuff most of us know anthony
bourdain through his tv shows but he
worked in restaurants nearly half his
life throughout the 1980s and 90s he and
a group of friends bounced from one new
york city restaurant to the next after
he died by suicide in 2018 fans set up a
memorial outside one of those
restaurants and that's where we gathered
some of his friends
how does it feel to be back in this
place
it's complicated we met in the former
restaurant layoff two green salads
followed by two-fold delay
where anthony bourdain had worked as a
chef and posed for the cover of his
breakout book kitchen confidential this
was placed so
very much associated with tony laurie
woolever was bourdain's assistant and
writing partner i have a memory from it
when tony first started working here
writer joel rose was his friend just
hanging out downstairs with him
preparing steaks we did a lot of shoots
here for tony's various shows nari kai
worked as a producer on bourdain's tv
shows whenever we had to pick a location
be like well go to leia he used to be
tony here a lot chef patty jackson met
bourdain in the kitchen a different one
all restaurants are haunted but this
restaurant for me is very haunted is it
yeah i mean in a nice way they're good
memories but
but there are memories will ever has
gathered these memories for her new book
bourdain the definitive oral biography
the stories from friends and family
paint a picture of a complex man who
never quite settled he was terrified
that he was going to work on the line
for the rest of his life and in the
kitchen yeah and he was scared of that
this is what i've been doing every day
for 28 years that no sane person would
want to do this and he saw writing as a
way out he was hoping that it might be
bourdain's work hard party harder
lifestyle had taken its toll
addicted to heroin he was high when he
first met rose who was running a
literary magazine out of his apartment
bourdain submitted a comic book by mail
i wrote back to this person
your drawing sort of sucks
but your writing is good yeah
and the next thing i know
uh somebody rang my buzzer and there was
this very tall guy there in chefs whites
that guy was bourdain right from the
get-go i knew that he was a talented
writer and a great storyteller rose
helped bourdain get the deal to publish
kitchen confidential changed everything
changed everything for all of us really
it led to bourdain's tv shows no
reservations
and changed everything for nari kai too
meet nari she works in our office she'd
been working for his show no
reservations when she drunkenly
suggested at a wrap party that bourdain
visited her home country korea
he took her up on the offer
nari's enormous energy and excitement
for her homeland is why i've come
growing up in america as an immigrant
there's a lot of racism a lot of
bullying and a lot of shame on my you
know on my part of just wanting to fit
in and it wasn't until tony was like
actually this is your contribution your
unique heritage and your unique point of
view i mean koreans are a brave people i
mean who else would eat this right i
mean
me
and for me as a creative person it
fueled everything that i do well i'm
psyched my dream has finally come true
bourdain's drive for travel and
adventure kept him on the road
constantly let's wrap it up boys we've
got places to go sometimes 250 days a
year what was that all about do you
think i don't think there was enough in
the world sometimes to really keep him
occupied i don't know if he was
trying to escape in some ways from
things or if he was trying to absorb
more things i think that a lot of the
passions that he had
were actually a form of addiction
and the travel
to
and and why he did it even when he was
so run down it wasn't until he passed
away that i realized
that
darkness that he possessed we're always
going going going he did have this the
sadness and i think his work kept him
distracted from that it's a gift
a dream
a curse
the best thing
the happiest thing
yet also
the loneliest thing in the world
bourdain's impact on those around him
was so profound
that when he took his life in 2018 for
many it left a deep void
there's a quote from sally freeman in in
the book and she said when i heard the
news he died i thought so many people
have lost their anchor why was he an
anchor for a lot of people
well i think he was so relatable right
you know sharing his story of of working
hard and having disappointments and and
defeats and also lots of victories
everyone felt connected to him people
who didn't know him felt connected to
him
and still do yeah and still do yeah what
is that power he cared about everybody
astonishing
unbelievable private in new york he was
really loyal
really dedicated person and
i think that translated in his work
he was a seeker he was a dreamer he had
passions and ideas and he found a way to
live that life that's gonna be good this
is something that he left behind is his
passion
to want to try something new try a new
food talk to a person you wouldn't talk
to go somewhere you haven't been to grow
as a human being that was his greatest
gift we all miss him
every day
next month a restaurant formerly known
as layal will start a new chapter as an
alsatian eatery la brassary by francis
staub we thank them for letting us use
the restaurant but as you can see
bourdain left a permanent mark on the
places he went and more deeply on the
people he met certainly tell that
because he had been on our show shortly
before he died he was in the green room
raving about his little daughter and he
had just come off the road yeah so i
remember being so shocked by it i can't
imagine how what his friends were
thinking i love what the chef said to
you was he trying to escape or absorb
yeah and probably both i mean that's the
thing you come down to i mean that
number 250 days on the road
means startles me every time i hear it
yeah i mean that takes a real toll and
you know it cries an enormous amount of
energy and it also means
you're not settled yeah did these
conversations shed more of a light on
why he was so conflicted i think you
know it goes back to i mean the thing
that they kept pointing out was look he
had he was an addict he was a heroin
addict you know for a time when he was a
chef and and so that may have influenced
him down the road i don't know enough
about addiction to to know the the
influence but it clearly played a role
as they pointed out i love that line all
restaurants are haunted i guess some
more than most it's interesting that his
old restaurant will now become something
else it was very interesting to see the
reaction wall to being there oh bad i'll
bet it was a great restaurant too thank
you anthony always good to have you here